look
[Music]
hello happy friday november 13
health andrés gonzález and these are the
most important news of the day
the board of directors of
the clark county school district decided to
postpone the vote to reopen the
schools yesterday after hours of
discussion board members
decided to defer voting on the
proposed hybrid plan that would reopen
school sites in january the
board also did not release a
date they plan to vote on the plan
a string of earthquakes struck
central  snowfall this morning
more than 50 tremors were recorded
starting at one in the morning in the
emirates area one for most of the
tremors they were mild but if there was one
that registered 5.5 on the richter scale
so far they have not been reported  know
reports of injuries or damages
the authorities are attentive to the
figures of cases of influenza in this
winter season officials of the
district of health of the  southern nevada
said that although the threat of a rise
in influenza cases in
clark county is minimal they are watching the
figures with caution they added that for
now flu cases are not
impacting medical services in
hospitals
and talking about  the flu if you haven't
gotten a flu shot there will be a
free flu shot clinic this coming
saturday immunization organization efforts
nevada is sponsoring the
administration of shots from 9
am to noon at the college
of pharmacy on rosso campus  and
university located on calle sánchez
road next to the seattle chocolate factory
at the clinic will only be
available to patients over the age of
19 but they are asked to bring
their face masks and health insurance card
the vaccinations are free with the
most medical plans
and by the weekend temperatures
will be in the 60s to 70s with
mostly sunny skies and p  For all of
next week we will have temperatures
in the 30s I wish you a happy
weekend informed Andrés González
with his brief news now in
Spanish
[Music]